>>Karen: Okay, I'm not sure a man who's been
entertaining a group with stories and keeping
these rapt faces out of their laptop needs
an introduction.
I also don't think the mikes working, so I'm
gonna put it down and just talk.
How about this?
Photo op there we go.
>>Sully: Improvise, we can improvise here.
>>Karen: This is awesome.
So I'm Karen May for those of you I don't
know.
Oh this is, wow what an introduction.
I manage our talent team which is leadership
development, learning and development, talent
management and so forth.
And so what an honor for me to introduce this
man I'm so close to.
To introduce to you Sully Sullenberger who
you may know as a hero and you may think of
when you think of the word hero.
But you may also think of as a leader, as
a man who's an expert, who's responsible,
who's creative and who's able to lead a team
through a significant crisis to a very good
end.
Right?
Yes, he's standing here, very good end.
But I wanted to highlight three other characteristics,
leadership characteristics that really matter.
The first is he's a curious man.
Even after extraordinary success he stays
curious.
And the second is that he's focused on learning
from others.
Even people who are quite different from him.
And then the third is that he seeks to share
that knowledge, to share what he learns.
And he actually took this book that he wrote,
"Making a Difference", the one he's here to
talk to us about as an opportunity to interview
people, 11 people that he admires.
Leaders that he admires.
And to learn from them and then in turn to
share what he learned with the world.
And he's here today to share that with you,
and what an honor for us.
So thank you.
[Applause]
>>Sully: Thank you, thank you so much.
>>Karen: I'll just stay here.
>>Sully: [Laughs]
That was a very nice introduction, thank you
I'll try to live up to it.
But yeah I have been intellectually curious
my whole life.
And in the introduction to the second book,
"Making a Difference: stories in vision and
courage from America's leaders," I talk about
why that's the case or why I think that's
the case.
And one of the reasons is that even before
my birth my family valued education.
All four of my grandparents and these are
people who were born in the 1880s and 1890s,
in the 19th century went to college.
And that was especially remarkable for women
of that era.
My mother was a first grade teacher in this
small town in Texas where I grew up.
A first grade teacher for 25 years, and so
from her I got wonderful lifelong gifts of
a love of reading and of learning and those
have served me well throughout my career.
And so I've tried to do what I've encouraged
others to do and that's to continue to invest
in yourself.
Never stop learning, never stop growing either
professionally or personally throughout your
life.
And I think that's become a necessity now
because with the pace of change only accelerating
I think most people cannot get through an
entire working lifetime with just one skill
set.
We have to keep learning, have to keep growing
sometimes reinvent ourselves like I did on
January 15, 2009 to learn very quickly a way
of living this entirely new life.
On January 15, 2009 I had never given a public
speech in my life.
Never wanted to, I was convinced that wouldn't
be good at it.
I'd never written a book.
I'd been a professional pilot, but I stayed
curious.
And so I approached these new careers, and
I have four of them now to replace the airline
career I left after 30 years two years ago.
As a speaker, as an author as a consultant
to industry and as a CBS news aviation consultant.
I approach that with the same discipline and
diligence I did in my flying career.
And we seem to have lost the speaker in the
room or is it just been muted?
>>Male #1: I think it's better without it.
>>Sully: Is it better without it?
>>Male #2: I think we've got a little bit
of speaker.
>>Sully: Okay, I've got just enough that you
can hear me let me know if you can't.
So why this book and why now?
I think, like the first book, "Highest Duty,"
my memoir, a lot of this book was already
in me.
That I had lived my life in a way that had
prepared me without knowing it for that event
and for all this attention as a public figure
and the aftermath.
I'd been thoughtful, I grew up in an environment
in which ideas were important and in which
education was important.
And striving for excellence was expected of
me.
And so when I had these amazing opportunities
to travel the world and meet world figures
the last three years.
And I began to hear these very personal stories,
these moving and inspiring stories sometimes
funny but all of them really incredible.
About people who have changed the world, who
have changed the lives of others and done
amazing things, I just had to share them,
I had to put them on a page.
And so that's why.
And I intentionally chose a very diverse group
of people from a variety of walks of life.
Younger and older, men, women, some well know
some you've never heard of.
But all people that I admire and respect.
All people who have certain things in common.
One of the things they have in common is that
I think they all view the world the same way.
They view the world as an opportunity for
good.
And they're people who are willing to serve
a cause greater than themselves, greater than
their own immediate needs.
They're people who like one of them literally
says, they're able to check their ego at the
door.
They're able to do things for the right reasons.
And they're able to lead people.
You know I think people deserve to be led,
that they want to be led.
We may manage things, we may manage money,
but we must lead people, and that requires
human skills.
You know some, especially in really evidence-based
domains and I've done a lot of patient safety
work too, trying to apply what we've learned
over the last century in aviation to medicine.
Some in these evidence-based domains like
medicine think of these human skills as soft
skills as opposed to hard skills or clinical
or technical skills.
But they're not really soft skills or human
skills.
And even in medicine, even in an evidence
based domain like that these human skills
have the potential to save more lives than
technical skills do.
Because much of what we're seeing in medicine
right now is we have like in so many industries
islands of excellence in a sea of systemic
failures.
We have some areas that are doing very well,
some that are very safe and some that are
not.
And so I think these human skills are very
important.
And now when we as a society are facing huge
and intractable and ambiguous and complicated
problems that are going to require generations
to solve, we need people now more than ever
who can feel a sense of civic duty.
Who can be willing to share sacrifices.
Who can give us a vision of a possible future
and help us to get there.
And be as Jennifer Granholm says, a former
Michigan Governor who I profile in the book,
"Who can be more pragmatic and less dogmatic?"
So with that in mind, I can, I'll tell you
a few stories about some of the people in
my profile and why I chose them.
And then I'd like to open it up into a wide
ranging discussion about what these people
mean, what they've done and what we can learn
from them and take away as everyday things
we can use in our lives.
And one of the things I wanted to do in this
book is to make it accessible.
There are shelves full of leadership books,
but many of them are written by or for CEOs
or salespeople.
But this book is for everybody.
Whether you have a big job or a fancy title
or not.
Everybody can learn to be a leader and everybody
can learn to be a better leader than they
are currently.
The very first profile I do is as Admiral
Thad Allen.
You may know the name, he's a recently retired
coastguard commandant.
Just about a contemporary of mine, maybe a
year to two older.
He spent his whole life serving others, saving
lives.
And he was the one brought in in the darkest
hours of the federal response to Hurricane
Katrina to turn it around.
It was in chaos, it was uncoordinated.
The rescue workers were being beaten up in
the press on a daily basis.
They were completely demoralized.
And so when he finally got to New Orleans
he turned to his military aid who happened
to be interestingly enough named Katrina.
[Laughter]
And she said, "Well Admiral, now that we're
here what are you going to do?"
And he said, "I'm gonna do the first thing
that any new commander does, I'm gonna call
an all hands meeting."
And she said, "Admiral there are 4000 people
in this building."
And he said, "I want to gather as many of
them in one place as you can and I want to
talk to them right now."
And so on the first floor of this large building
they gathered 2500 people.
And as he entered the area, he saw faces almost
hanging on the floor.
And so he stood up on a desk, he grabbed a
microphone and then with a very simple message
in just a few words he said, "I want you to
listen to me I'm going I'm going to give you
a direct order.
I want you to treat everyone you encounter
as if they were a member your immediate family.
As if they were your father, your mother,
your brother, your sister.
And if you do that two things are going to
happen.
First if you make a mistake you're going err
on the side of doing too much not too little.
And second if anyone has a problem with what
you've done, then their problem is with me
and not with you."
And he said you could hear a huge collective
sigh of relief people actually began to weep
because nobody before that had told them that
what they were doing was important or why
or that their boss was behind them.
And in just a few words he had done that.
For a very graphic exercise of leadership
by his personal example.
And he did the same thing again with the BP
oil spill in the Gulf and with the response
to the earthquake in Haiti in 2010.
And that's just one story, one profile and
the first chapter of the book.
And there are so many that are like that.
Robert Reich was here I know and spoke to
you last August.
I had an extended conversation with him.
I've admired him for many years.
And my conversation with him in his office
over at Berkeley was by far the most intellectually
stimulating of them all.
It was almost a Socratic dialogue.
And we talked about many things.
He talked about where he got his inspiration.
He's a little bit older than I and in the
early 1960s during the civil rights movement
one of his close friends, a mentor, a man
a little bit older than he is Mickey Schwerner
who you may remember was murdered along with
two other civil rights workers in Mississippi
that led to the story and movie "Mississippi
Burning".
And when Robert, when Bob learned about this
man's death it shocked him to the core.
That such evil could exist in our country,
in this time.
And he made a promise to himself that he would
do what he had the inclination to do and what
he said was an assumption that he would do,
he would assume that he would spend his life
in what he calls public service.
Now that sounds like an archaic term doesn't
it?
It's not one commonly hears these days.
But this is literally what he means is that
he intended to spend his life serving the
public.
And it wasn't that he was going to go into
politics or become a politician or to work
in government, his goal was to be a public
servant which is what he did.
He relates to me another example of his personal
leadership.
When he first got to the Labor Department
as the new labor secretary under President
Clinton, he had a meeting with his staff.
And he opened it up to questions.
A large group of employees in the Labor Department.
And someone asked him, "Mr. Secretary, why
do we still have time cards?
Why do we have to mess with that?
What's purpose of that?"
And so he canvassed his lieutenants and they
decided that there really wasn't a purpose
to the time cards.
And so he said, "Okay starting next week no
more time cards."
And people were stunned.
But then more suggestions came, and people
became more engaged and had other ways to
make things better and more productive and
more useful.
And one of the best ideas that came out of
this meeting was to as changes to the economy
took place to try to very quickly identify
which jobs were likely to go away and never
come back.
And which jobs in which someone could be quickly
retrained to do something else similar.
And then to redeploy the forces and the resources
to do the most good.
So in a sense doing triage.
One name that you haven't heard is Sue Sheridan.
And through my patient safety work I became
familiar with her story through a physician
friend of mine.
Sue Sheridan is a mother of two from Boise
Idaho.
And the reason I profile her is because her
family endured two awful and preventable medical
tragedies.
First her son Cal when he was born as many
babies do became jaundiced.
He wasn't diagnosed, he wasn't tested, he
wasn't treated in time and he suffered brain
damage.
He has cerebral palsy and he requires special
care the rest of his life.
And not long after that, her husband Pat had
a tumor that they were initially told was
benign.
He had surgery to remove as much of it as
could be done.
And then when the tumor recurred the surgeons
at that time wondered why he wasn't treated
for cancer earlier at the time of his first
surgery.
They kept saying, "Well because we were told
it was benign."
And after about the third of fourth Doctor
or pathologist asked her the same question,
why wasn't he treated earlier for cancer?
She went down to the records room and checked
out his records herself and saw on the original
pathology report malignant sarcoma.
And so again a systemic breakdown in communication
led to a fatality.
And as he was dying he made her promise to
go kick some ass, to save others from that
fate, and to change the world.
And so rather than devolve into bitterness,
anger and despair as many would feel every
right to do she educated herself.
She gained allies.
She took on the often imperious medical establishment
as a mom.
And she single-handedly managed to change
the care that we give newborns globally.
And she now has a new job that I helped her
get as a patient safety advocate as part of
the World Health Organization.
It's amazing what people can do when they
choose to.
So that's why I wrote the book and for me
that's what it's about.
It's that each of us can choose to do these
things.
Each of us can learn to be more fulfilled
at work to be better leaders at home, at school
or at work.
But let's take your questions.
We have some mikes that we'll pass through
the room and if we all can't hear you clearly
that I'll repeat the question.
Right over here, yes sir.
I remember seeing you before, good to see
you again.
>>Male #3: Whoops, I am on.
Good to see you again, thanks for coming.
In terms of making a difference, you went
from being an airline pilot getting being
ready to retire to becoming an advocate for
aviation safety.
I'm wondering, you see you've been making
good use of this, the bully pulpit.
[Microphone Feedback] these are things that
we are seeing wrong with the way that airlines
are regulated, the ways that pilots and flight
crews are being compensated, recognized.
Are you starting to see any progress, any
response from policymakers and from the airlines
to that work?
>>Sully: Some.
The answer in order is yes from some of the
policymakers and pretty much no from the industry.
We have in this country a formal lessons learned
process through the National Transportation
Safety Board.
An independent federal agency that investigates
major transportation accidents, not just airlines
but rail, pipeline, highway and others.
As a result of the final report on flight
1549 the final report was issued just about
two years ago.
Some two dozen recommendations were made to
make the system safer, to make this kind of
an accident less likely to happen in the future.
And let me ask you what you think the result
has been.
Of those two dozen recommendations made by
this independent agency that's charged with
making the recommendations but cannot themselves
implement them.
It's a province of our regulatory agency the
FAA to change the rules and the airlines to
adopt them.
Of the two dozen, how many do you think have
been implemented thus far?
How many think that half have been raise your
hand?
How many think five have been?
Gosh you guys are a cynical bunch.
[Laughter]
How many of you think two have been?
And how many think one has been?
Does anybody think none has been?
You're right.
[Laughter]
You're right thus far none of the recommendations
has been implemented.
And so to get back to your question right
now aviation is ultra-safe but if we're going
to keep it at that level and make it better
which is what we should be doing because our
passengers deserve and expect it.
We got to do more work than we're doing right
now.
Unfortunately just a month after our flight
in February 2009 in Buffalo New York there
was a crash that claimed 50 lives.
The Continental Connection Culkin air 3407.
49 on the airplane and one person on the ground
whose house the crash hit.
The families of the victims of the Culkin
air crash have been ardent and tireless advocates
of safety.
And they've been very active lobbying legislators
on capital here.
They've been lobbying the airline industry.
And it's largely through their efforts with
some help from me and my first officer on
my flight Jeff Skiles that we got through
the Congress two bills that passed in the
fall of 2009 and the summer of 2010 that have
required greater experience for pilots especially
young pilots in the regional airlines from
the unbelievable low minimum level now of
250 hours to be an airline pilot.
It's laughably small to at least 1500 hrs.
And also to improve the rules that prevent
pilot fatigue.
But you know what, the airline industry and
their lobbyists are fighting as hard as they
can tooth and nail.
They're spending millions of dollars to fight
this, to weaken it, to delay it, to kill it.
I've had them personally call me a liar.
I've had them fight in every way that they
can to say that this isn't necessary, that
we really, it's okay the way it is.
It's good enough.
And of course it isn't.
So were fighting entrenched interests who
have a big financial stake in the status quo.
And I don't see that happening anytime soon.
And unfortunately in our society like every
other it almost takes a crisis to focus the
public attention and political will to get
these things done.
And as we recede in time from these events
and we get back to business as normal and
those that we're opposing can say, "Well we
haven't killed anybody lately so were doing
everything okay."
And were saying, "You can't define safety
only that way, you have to look proactively
at the risks and vindicate them."
It's gonna be an ongoing battle.
Yes sir.
>>Male #4: It seems to me like him NTSB is
unusually competent and effective if underpowered
whereas the FAA suffers from regulatory capture
and terrible inertia and bureaucracy.
You can be forgiven if you want to punt on
this question because it's political.
Why do you think that the in NTSB has that
spark whereas the FAA is like many other regulatory
agency's not.
>>Sully: I think it's twofold.
First the NTSB is an independent agency.
It's somewhat more insulated from the political
process although not completely by any means.
And also just a practical matter the rulemaking
agency the FAA is the one that's going to
impose costs on the operators.
It's the one that's going to make the rules
that determine how much it costs them to operate
in accordance with the new standards.
How inconvenient it is for them, and of course
they and their lobbyists are fighting anything
that's deemed to be either the least bit more
costly or the least but more inconvenient
for them.
And that they view as a regulatory burden
quite frankly.
And so I think it's just a matter of practicality,
it's the rulemaking process where the differences
are made.
And that's where the cost are gonna be felt.
So I think it's not just the FAA, I think
that many of the federal agencies have that
problem.
And I think it's, whether it's in the financial
world where we're seeing these kinds of things
happening are on Capitol Hill.
The influence of money is too great in our
society and I'm not going to punt on a political
question even though this is not a really
political book I don't shy away from answering
or addressing an important questions that
people care about that affect our lives.
And the influence of money is too great in
our entire political system.
And it's even worse now after that wrongheaded
Supreme Court decision in Citizens United
that gives corporations the ability to donate
to unlimited sums, and super pacs.
And it disenfranchises the rest of us because
the lobbyists can get the rules written in
their favor.
And it's not in the favor of the traveling
public, it's not the favor of the average
Americans it's in favor of specific industries
or specific companies.
>>Male #4: On a more hopeful note, do you
know of any recipes to have more agencies
like the NTSB that could perhaps help to regulate
the financial industry and some of the other
risk areas where it wouldn't suffer from the
same political shenanigans?
>>Sully: I think having longer terms would
help.
And having appointees that are more based
on competence and not political affiliation.
Again I get back to my response to when people
have on occasion asked me my political affiliation.
And I anticipated very early on, I mean three
years plus that that question would eventually
he asked.
I've been shocked and surprised that it's
only been asked twice in 3 1/2 years.
But I had a ready answer and it's not a flippant
one it's a real answer.
When people ask me if I'm a Republican or
a Democrat I say I'm an American, and I think
as an American and I vote as an American and
I wish more of us did that.
Yes ma'am back here in the back.
>>Female #1: Yes hi.
>>Female #2: Wait wait wait.
I'm sorry, do we have somebody else first?
Should I wait for the mike?
>>Female #3: Thank you so much for coming
to speak with us.
My question for you is about how we can teach
the next generation of leadership.
You mention in your book that leadership is
accessible, it's for all of us.
I'm sure that's true for the younger generation.
But you talk about your daughters, and I'm
just curious if you could share with us how
we can teach leadership to that next generation.
>>Sully: Through your own personal example,
by modeling the behavior you want to see in
them.
They are not going to listen to what you say
as much as what they'll watch what you do.
And our daughters and are 19 and 17.
And my wife is a wonderful partner and a wonderful
mom and I think part of the reason that they
turned out the way they are is it's in their
DNA.
And my daughters are adopted, so they're not
biologically related to us directly.
But part of who they are is our DNA, but that's
only a part of it.
My wife has done a great job of being there
for them, mentoring them.
We read to them from a very early age and
cuddled with them even before they could even
understand the words.
And it was really fun to see them then try
to "read" even before they could to their
stuffed animals or to their dolls.
Or the older one to the younger one, mimicking
what we had done with them.
So I would say just act around them the way
you want them to act in every way.
The words you choose, the way you treat shopkeepers
or people you pass on the highway.
Whatever it is, they will notice what you've
done.
It's one of the things I say in the book about
my time as a captain, and practicing for 22
years of a captain out of my 30 years as an
airline pilot.
Meeting a new group of people, a new crew
every week and trying to quickly take this
collection of individuals, some of whom may
not even know each other and form a team.
So if something bad happens on the first takeoff
we can work together effectively and solve
the problem.
And I say in the book that few interactions
with others went unnoticed or were completely
without consequence.
People notice those things, or as I say about
my friend Chris who died of cancer three years
ago.
And I spoke at his memorial service, Chris
was able to live his life in such a way that
his values were apparent.
He didn't have to tell you what he believed,
you could see in his actions and in his attitudes
what he believed.
That would be it I think.
Yes over there.
>>Male #5: You mentioned the people you interviewed
for this book are people that made you feel
inspired.
If one day I would write a book like this,
you would be one of those people for me.
[mike feedback].
>>Sully: Thank you.
>>Male #5: My question is there any additional
stories that you wanted to put into the book
but weren't able to?
>>Sully: Oh gosh that's a great question.
Fortunately just about everybody I asked to
interview said yes.
They were very anxious to be a part of this
progress, process which was wonderful.
Are there stories that I would like to have
included that I didn't have time to?
Yes absolutely, there was one I touch on briefly.
One of the people I really wanted to interview
and wasn't able to make our schedules mesh
was now the Secretary of Veterans Affairs,
the former four-star Army general Chief of
Staff of the Army Eric Shinseki.
He as a young infantry officer in Vietnam,
badly wounded, lost part of one foot.
Served with distinction throughout his entire
career, rose to the highest rank in the Army
and is now as Veterans Affairs secretary trying
to do his very best to give the best care
for our veterans that we can.
One thing in particular that really caught
my attention about him in terms of his personal
moral courage.
Early in 2003 before the March invasion of
Iraq he was asked to testify before Congress
about the numbers of ground troops that would
be required to control, to pacify the country
after the invasion phase was over.
And he testified truthfully, or rightly about
the fact that several hundred thousand would
be required which was a much larger number
than then secretary of defense Donald Rumsfeld
was publicly stating along with the rest of
the administration.
And he paid a political and professional price
for that and ended up retiring and leaving
and not being able to continue.
And I think that was just a perfect example
of the kind of moral courage I'm talking about,
that I admire in many of these people.
I would like to have told more of his story
and meet him personally and I wasn't able
to make our schedules work.
>>Female #4: A question about when you actually
landed the plane.
I imagine there may have been times when,
I think you said it was very grueling following
the established processes [Inaudible].
But I wonder did you also have to break rules
and processes and potentially handle conflict,
perhaps with your [Inaudible] about what to
do?
Was there conflict with the rules and processes
[Inaudible] and how did you make the choices
that you made?
>>Sully: That's a great question, it's a big
question and I'll try to distill it down to
its essential elements.
What happened to us on January 15th 2009 on
flight 1549 was extraordinary.
It was very rare statistically to have an
airliner hit either so many birds or such
large birds that it basically disabled it
and damaged the engines.
It turns out irreparably.
Then leading to an engine out emergency landing
in water just 208 seconds after we had left,
just under 3 1/2 minutes.
So that was something, it was a novel and
unanticipated event for which we had never
specifically trained.
So it was very much outside the box.
And there wasn't an exact protocol to follow
in that case.
And so yes it required a great deal of improvisation,
it required a great deal of deciding that
many of the things that we're taught to do
in less dire situations weren't really appropriate
in that situation.
I'll try to go through a few of them really
quickly.
The fact that this happened so soon, just
100 seconds after takeoff at such a low altitude,
about 2700 feet with so few options over one
of the most densely developed populated areas
of the planet, Manhattan meant that we had
to act very quickly, very decisively to make
tough choices, to get them right immediately
based upon imperfect and ambiguous information.
The big advantage that we had was that unlike
some other situations, unlike Air France 447
for example where there was some ambiguity
about exactly what was going on, we knew clearly
exactly what happened, exactly why and what
that entailed for us.
There was no doubt about what had happened,
so that part of the situation was actually
very clear and relatively easy.
The difficult part was that the stress levels
were so high that they were marginally debilitating.
It didn't leave me with the ability to do
the math on the altitude and distance quite
frankly.
So what I did was I relied upon my experience
of having flown thousands of flights, 20,000
hours.
And I was able to look out the window over
my shoulder, look at the nearer runways and
say, "No."
And be right.
Very quickly under those conditions was remarkable
because the NTSB as is their charter spent
a year and a half thoroughly investigating
every aspect of this including computer simulations
to determine if theoretically we had enough
energy, we had enough altitude speed.
You know the one half MB squared part of it,
the kinetic energy to make it to a runway,
taking into account human reaction time.
It turns out we did not by a little bit.
And after, remember when you were a kid and
they would say don't get into trouble a we'll
put it on your permanent record?
Well if there is such a thing it's probably
having an in NTSB report written about you.
Where they literally scrutinize for a year
and a half every thought that we had, every
syllable we uttered, every choice we made,
every action that we took.
And to have us be vindicated after that process,
I was very happy with it.
One of the other things that we did that's
not typical is in a less dire emergency it's
thought best based upon the data we've had,
the studies that have been done for the captain
not to fly the airplane but to be the decision-maker
and take in the whole situation, be aware
of all the predictable parameters.
To make a choice announce it and begin directing
the first officer to take certain actions,
there wasn't time for that.
The work load was so intense, the time pressure
so extreme that Jeff Stiles my first officer
and I never had time to even discuss the situation.
We had simply to act, and so it was best that
I fly rather than try to direct him because
there wasn't time.
And so I called for the checklist, I began
making a left turn sort of taking actions
by memory because there wasn't time to again
one of the other protocols we deviated from
was rather than wait until a minute plus later
over a third of the way through remaining
flight time when we finally got to this part
of the checklist where we first would start
taking remedial actions like turning on the
engine ignition, starting the auxiliary power
unit to provide a backup source of electrical
generation, I took them in the first 2 seconds
by memory.
But there were several ways that we deviated
from the normal course of things just due
to the exigencies.
And that was critical, had I not done so we
couldn't have had as good an outcome.
So this whole thing was one series of improvisations
after another but done based upon 42 years
of flying, 20,000 hours in the air and having
a clear understanding of the end state I was
going to achieve.
And knowing which options were possible and
which ones were not by looking out the window
and being right.
So that's what we did.
There was a question up here that we have
been neglecting.
>>Male #6: I have a short one.
What would you suggest that?
>>Sully: Hold on a minute
>>Male #6: What would you suggest for engineers
who are working safety bases?
>>Sully: I'm sorry, one more time.
>>Male #6: What can you suggest engineers
who are working on safety critical systems?
>>Sully: A couple of things to do.
I would say the engineers who are working
on safety critical systems to realize that
just as in medicine, just as in aviation,
just as in many other critical industries
what we have now are human technology systems
that must function together seamlessly.
And we need to involve the end-users as early
as possible in the system design.
We need to take advantage of the limitations
and the abilities of the technology and of
the humans and assign them appropriate roles
accordingly.
For example in aviation as in many domains
technology is great, it affords us wonderful
functionality, wonderful displays of information,
high levels of integration of electronic connectedness.
But the downside of that is that technology
for the most part can only do what has been
foreseen and programed.
It's humans who can innovate.
And by the way, my favorite definition of
innovation is changing before you're forced
to.
By regulation, by competition, by circumstance.
And so what we did that day was to innovate
and the technology helped us to some extent
but it was basically hand, manually flying
and making choices in terms of our human capabilities.
So I would say keep the human factor in mind.
Your engineering can be top-rated, first rate,
but if you don't take into account sufficiently
appropriately the, how humans are going to
use it, the fact that humans are going to
make mistakes and your systems need to be
tolerant of that and to make them as least
likely as possible and you can still fail
and fail spectacularly if you don't do that.
Yes sir.
>.Male #7: With that in mind how do you feel
about Airbus's programmed flight envelope
and how it takes it all away from the pilot.
>>Sully: I, the short answer is I prefer Boeing's
philosophy which is that when you approach
certain limitations it will warn you, the
stick may shake or it may make a noise.
But if you must go beyond that to avoid hitting
the ground, to avoid a collision, it's possible
to do so.
People have asked me if we would've had a
similar outcome in a Boeing airplane that
day and my answer is I think we would have
as long as it was the general geometric layout
was similar, in the airplanes shape and size
were similar we would've had a similar outcome.
The Airbus I was flying was a fly by wire
airplane in which there is no longer a direct
mechanical connection between the flight controls
in the cockpit, and the flight control circuits
in the wings and tail.
Instead there are flight control computers
that interpret and mediate the pilots inputs
and then send electrical impulses to actuators
that move the control surfaces.
The flight envelope protections that the Airbus
fly by wire system affords us we didn't need
because we never got to the maximums at which
it would have essentially protected us from
seeing certain limitations.
And in one important way it hindered us and
this has not been well told, well known.
We look at the digital flight data recorder
that has all kinds of streams of data, all
the flight control positions, altitude, airspeed,
acceleration etc.
And in the last 4 seconds of flight, that's
right before we touched down I was not yet
achieving the maximum lift from the wings.
I was commanding for more, pulling back full
aft on the stick and the flight control computers
prevented me from getting more lift therefore
we hit harder than we would have, there was
more damage underneath, more water came in
sooner.
One structural piece of metal was driven up
through the back floor which cut Doreen Welsh,
the flight attendants, leg.
So that was not the way we were trained it
would work.
It turns out there's a little-known software
feature known only then to a few Airbus software
engineers, and to no pilots to no airlines
that was the case.
It's called a phugoid mode.
And it was not the way we were trained the
airplane should work, apparently it is the
way the airplane does work.
But that was not apparent to us and so in
that sense it actually hurt us.
>>Male #5: Was it in direct law?
>>Sully: No, he's asking if we were in direct
law.
And there are three categories of sophistication
that are possible in the Airbus flight control
system.
The highest level, the normal level is called
normal law in which everything is working
and all these flight protections are intact.
It prevents you from going too fast or too
slow, or too high or too low, too much bank
too much acceleration in terms of G.
In alternate law you have some of those protections
but not all of them.
That's a degraded mode but the flight control
protections are still somewhat active.
In direct law none of the flight control protections
is active, it's possible to aerodynamically
stall the wing, it won't prevent you from
doing that and it flies more like a more conventional
airplane.
Now we stayed in normal law the entire time
because in the first 2 seconds I started our
airplanes auxiliary power unit and by the
time the left engine ripped up, the speed,
RPMs decayed below the point at which the
left generator could continue power on electrical
buses the APU generator was online.
So we remained in normal law and all those
protections were intact.
>>Male #7: We don't care about Republican
or Democrat, we just Airbus versus Boeing.
[Laughter]
>>Sully: Okay.
Alright let's see who else, there must be
some others.
Yes sir, right here.
>>Male #8: So you have mentioned about the
increasing flight time requirements from 250
hours to 1500 hours.
>>Sully: Yes.
>>Male #8: So what kind of advice would you
give to younger pilots to get through that
grind?
Those who dream of being an airline pilot.
>>Sully: How do you get from 200, if you want
to be a pilot at you get from 250 hours to
1500 hours?
Well that's, I think you'll do the same thing
that we've always done and if you don't go
through the military which there are fewer
options now.
And even if you decide to go that route you
owe the military more years to make up the
12 now versus the five or six it used to be,
you'll have to do something else.
But there are jobs out there and I think in
one way there probably are a few better situations.
It used to be that you would go to one type
of an operation to fly and maybe via flight
instructor and small single engine propeller
flights for a while.
And you would change companies and go somewhere
else to fly as copilot in a turboprop doing
charters.
And then eventually you could fly a Lear jet
someplace else.
Now there are a few more operations where
it's more vertically integrated and you'll
have more options to progress within that
same company.
But it's a difficult thing to do, you're right.
But there are options in spite of what the
regional Airlines Association lobbyists say
there are options besides just flying banner
tows along the beach or being a flight instructor
in small single engine airplanes.
But it's always been hard, and it's no easier
now but does it really matter?
I mean would you want to put your kids on
a regional jet where the first officer has
250 hours I wouldn't.
I mean it doesn't matter how hard it is it's
what's required.
Yes.
>>Male #9: Do you think a less experienced
pilot would've had a prayer?
>>Sully: I think it would've been much harder.
I think in every way whether it had been night,
whether it had still been snowing, whether
we were little bit further from the river
is.
If any of those things had changed it would've
been much harder and had I had with me, well
I'm assuming you're talking about both pilots.
Had the captain been less experienced it might
not have been as hardwired in his or her brain
a way of synthesizing a lifetime of experience
and training to come up with a way to solve
this new problem you've never seen before
in 208 seconds.
Had I had a less experienced first officer,
I still wouldn't have had time to direct them.
So it would've meant that I would've had to
do more things myself which I probably really
couldn't have done.
Because I was maxed out.
And I wouldn't have had as much help because
Jeff Stiles had also been a captain before
on a 737 before all the cutbacks had forced
him back into the right seat to be a first
officer again.
He also had 20,000 hours of flying time like
I did.
And so he intuitively and immediately grasped
the situation as it built as I did.
I didn't have to tell him what was going on,
he saw it and he knew it.
He was able to listen to my conversation with
the air traffic controller on the radio and
infer my intent.
He knew intuitively and immediately to shift
his priorities on his own initiative, I didn't
have a chance to tell him later in the flight
to stop trying to regain usable thrust, using
the checklist with what turned out to be these
irreparably damaged engines and instead by
calling out airspeed and altitude to me he
help me judge that final critical maneuver
at the height above the river.
Judging it visually at which I began raising
the nose to start to land.
If I'd waited too long, we have hit too hard,
wouldn't have gotten the nose up enough.
If I began to raise the nose too soon we go
to slow and drop and hit too hard.
So he had to call out the airspeed and altitude
to me to help me judge that critical height.
So had either one of us been not as experienced
we could not have had as good an outcome.
Everything, every part of it would've been
harder that's why, we make it look so easy
being an airline pilot because so much goes
so right so much of the time.
But at any given moment you have to be able
to handle whatever the cosmos throws at you
even if it's never been thought of before.
And get it right the first time.
That's our job and that's why experience matters.
Are we out of time?
>>Male # 11: We're out of time, so a big round
of applause.
[Applause]
>>Sully: thank you, thank you.